[Music]
in groomzilla news
oh sure you guys go it's your mom I've
never heard of it I've never read either
okay cuz most guys only give a [ __ ] I
already hate this guy this guy's a [ __ ]
I know a groom's that laughs really
yeah my nail lady got engaged and her
her fiance's a groomzilla and he like
needed everything to be perfect he's
like crazy Wow
but I mean I'm not I don't I've never
met him so I can't really I just go by
her stories right yeah well I feel like
she's like I don't have anything to do
with my wedding like he's like been
great what then though most guys I know
don't give up I know choose everything
go choose everything go do everything
yeah I know what yeah yeah I didn't want
to do it either you didn't know much but
because he won't do it or like wouldn't
I was down for whatever you threw away
your nails are amazing so I like loved
the whole like I would listen to
anything if my nails look like that yeah
I've been staring at her nails like old
days oh stop flirting with TIFF I'm just
saying they're shining huh look at that
okay now cam all right let's go yours
are so white and right girl white and
right you know I just got mine not as
good not as if you're a true good until
you need to fix that [ __ ] okay all right
submitted by like a Western a groom says
his sister will be dead to him if she
misses his wedding for rehab oh I vote
having the wedding at the rehab who does
that there's some really pretty rehabs
here so cute
promises in Malibu yeah yeah yeah so
this was posted on reddit under
bridezillas
the subreddit bridezillas and the title
says groomzilla thinks his wedding is
more important than sister's sobriety
this is what it says
am I the [ __ ] for telling my daughter
that she doesn't have to go to my son's
wedding okay technically speaking my son
and daughter are my stepson and
stepdaughter but their bio mom passed
and their bio dad my ex-husband left
them when we were divorced and I was
their guardian until they turn 18 my
daughter is going through a tough time
right now she's an alcoholic and it's
currently in rehab after rehab she'll be
living
in a sober-living facility for 12 weeks
only a week after she leaves the sober
living facility assuming everything goes
according to plan is my son's wedding
though she hypothetically will be able
to resist temptation at that point I
don't think throwing her into a wedding
with an open bar is a good idea
especially considering that their
father's side of the family are rowdy
and heavy drinkers my daughter asked my
son if he would be upset if she stayed
home and they celebrated somewhere else
he told her that she would be dead to
him if she didn't come my daughter was
distraught and very emotional we talked
it out with her counselor and during the
conversation I told her that she should
stay home and that her sobriety was more
important than the wedding she reached
out to her brother and basically told
him exactly that and told him that I
said she could stay home my son is
extremely angry at me and accused me of
favoring my daughter by not supporting
him and that I might as well not come to
the wedding either
am I the [ __ ] for telling my daughter
does he not have any sympathy can I say
this as someone who's been divorced and
dealt with siblings that have gone
through addiction issues only because
you have that yes divorce rate is 51%
that's what the mom should sorry oh [ __ ]
you guys are married whoops I forgot
glad you're excited about the divorce
papers you're the pork that's more of an
insult how dare you is that a sports
well they're undefeated now so it's not
that much of it I don't even know what's
that moto Tigers fan I just know it's a
hockey team here in jail Oh or a part of
it it's a Super Bowl that's all that I
care about the Super Bowl
JLo and Shakira I don't care who goes
there even know I were gonna do any
sport I think I could catch a lot of
footballs with these huge hands that
I've got you do have giant honker fans
anyway that's what the mom should say
it's unsafe it's triggering don't be in
that environment and it's just it's not
healthy I think you should have more
empathy for sister
yeah the hub is the brother not like
have any sympathy at all and if he
really cares that much he should change
the date of his wedding to when she's
like okay and it's kind of hard to do
that because you don't ever really know
with you're not really fully
okay I'm always living with that yeah so
people have jumped in and someone said I
feel for both sides but her recovery
should be number one priority for
herself it's difficult dealing with
alcoholism as it is a family disease and
everyone suffers some help the brother
is the one causing all the issues he
needs to apologize so another one said
oh if they wondered why she drank his
behavior towards her might be a factor
well they don't blame it all on him I
know we were just commenting but this
other one said I understand she needs
help and she's trying to pull herself
together and that a wedding with alcohol
is not a good place for her but as as
the older sibling it really really wears
on you
her brother probably just wants her to
go for the ceremony and to take pictures
so for that one day it can be all about
him and it's not it's sad that his
sister is missing this and why don't you
plan this so your sister is comfortable
from dozens of relatives what are these
people who need to make everything about
them or what happens at weddings though
it's the worst thing I'll make it all
about them it's so annoying like my
wedding it's my day okay I'll call this
[ __ ] so [ __ ] boring isn't it nice
like being an actor and like performer
it's like you don't have to feel like
it's like oh yeah I think that's what it
was is like like at least with our
wedding like our photographers were like
you're the chillest bride I've ever met
cuz to me it didn't even feel like it
wasn't like I've dreamt about this day
all my life it was just like oh cool we
get to celebrate this milestone you know
just like fun
yeah that's how it should be yeah you
know cuz you did you ever play a bride
yeah I think I did yeah that veil is
like intense isn't it I guess sorry you
actually were married sorry yeah she's
married have you have you ever caught
the bouquet cuz it'd probably be pretty
easy without him it's like that I was
just at a woman I was just at a wedding
and I refused I refused to get on the
floor to catch it but you still caught
it
[Laughter]
I can look at this like it's like the
size of this like you think it'd sound
crazy
what do you fit your body you're crazy
girl no they don't
okay you know what they say about a girl
with big hands big personality big [ __ ]
big [ __ ] why do you think I like the
Luna egg so much bad no I haven't had
sex in so long I'm like a virgin he said
when you if you were getting fitted for
a clown costume would you ask them if
they have bigger gloves bigger pants for
my [ __ ] obviously the large and in
chart sorry
I thought I did it felt like it was a
physical violent situation that was
happening me clearly wasn't so what
happened with this um
no so I was just gonna give a little bit
more insight in that last like comment
that I read because it was a lot longer
and so they were saying that they are
the oldest of the family and they have
had some like a younger sibling ggest
sibling be the one that's like a wreck
that is always in and out of rehab and
every single important event in this
family and their families lives always
surrounded around that youngest sibling
and how like they just really just
absorbed all the attention because they
were such a wreck and so that's why this
person really related to the brother
where it's like can I just have one day
that's not about you like him you show
up to the wedding so no one not like the
entire wedding they don't spend it just
asking for you and then like at least
here in the photos you get to enjoy what
if she [ __ ] up at the wedding and she
gets drunk and then then it's about her
at the wedding
well then I think I think we also have
to think of his history right like he
was a Bandhan or something yeah like
someone died and then he was abandoned
and then now like the like the ex or
something so like I feel like that's
like his only family I was like [ __ ]
like please like I want my blood here he
wants to celebrate with him just not at
this open bar wedding no the mom this
the stepmom I wonder why so buddy of
mine buddy mine's a writer and he went
to kaley cuoco wedding the chick from
Big Bang Theory
man he said that these had to have spent
easily twenty million dollars in his
[ __ ] wedding what a mil it looked
really pretty alignment what he said
they had a [ __ ] tent just for whiskey
and he said they had like five of those
four with different whiskeys in like it
was [ __ ] nuts brother yeah so
disgusting it's too much money to spend
on it's pretty nice thing if you think
when it okay so if I spent twenty
million dollars on my wedding I don't
care if my whole family's alcoholics if
you're not coming your dicks I spent 20
mil on this [ __ ] I don't know if your
family doesn't like each other like dude
my mom locked herself in the bathroom so
I'm like a drowning cat for two hours
okay it's like better it was like maybe
my dad should have come last minute but
if you have a 29.4 wedding you could
have a whole tent just for one party
family one one whole tent for another
party I could have a tent for your hands
if I needed oh it's really what I was
trying to get a sponsorship
thank you yeah oh really no I got
married in a hotel room
Oh like I wished you were holding a
double vodka soda why you said that car
right no what was the question
Noelle married get married in a hotel
room yeah douche plane do explain reduce
plane with that yes what happened how
does that you're in a hotel room a rabbi
comes in a minister what happens the guy
who married um Krystal Hefner actually
married us oh you have his daughter
no what yo yo vich or however you say
her name Patty's their name yeah yeah
he was trying to hit on my sister
afterwards it was gonna creepy yeah
there's a resume of who he's married
yeah she look him up something marriage
you'll see like really good at it I
don't know I mean it was quick it was
easy but gosh how many people were in
the hotel room like 10 or 15 it was
really small was it like a like a sweet
like a big yeah it was like a it was
like a bungalow but there was like seats
and stuff it wasn't that sounds better
than a hotel room I was looking around I
think it like Bellagio like upstairs and
thought it was like a motel with a house
to twin size bed and I made in the
middle of it well I didn't plan anything
so like the night before there was
nothing ready like there was no seats
there was no flowers there was nothing I
was so poorly planned because I wasn't
thinking about it all happened so fast
why did it happen so bad because he
wanted to get married before the end of
the tax here because he was romantic we
were supposed to go there but the he I
know it you acted like I was random no I
just went through on vacation I didn't
go there but he was pressuring you to do
it there right no no no why Hawaii why
do you protest so much one no would have
been sufficient I wanted to get married
there that probably would have been much
more beautiful but you know I'm so glad
it didn't it's done yeah I'm free
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]